julia is on Twitter Dave can you explain
why you recommend opening up Roth I
arrays to contribute some of the 15%
rather than dropping all the 15% of the
company managed 401k my company matches
at 3% good question well start with
let's understand a company managed 401k
does not exist you have a company 401k
you manage it the money choices inside
the 401k are yours not your company's so
they don't manage the account you manage
what your investments are going into but
what we have figured out mathematically
when we say baby step 4 put 15% of your
household income add if you have two
incomes or three incomes add them all
together times 0.15 15% now that's the
dollar amount that should be going into
retirement the most efficient
mathematical process is to invest in
what we call rock paper scissors the
first one you want to do before you do
anything is take the match you have a 3%
match you want to take the match because
there's nothing that beats doubling your
money on day one if you put in a
thousand dollars they put in a thousand
dollars you made a hundred percent
return on your money before the mutual
fund performed that is what's known as
sweet so we always take the free money
up to the match and then we say Roth now
if you have a Roth 401k you could stay
with your 401k if you don't you would do
individual Roth's
or you may do both but you want to do
everything you can in Roth after match
and if you still haven't gotten to 15
percent after you maxed out all Roth
options available to you then you would
do traditional now why would I recommend
doing a Roth rather than traditional
which is kind of what you're asking all
right let's take a basic example of a
middle-class family making $50,000
household income 15 percent of that is
seven thousand five hundred dollars a
year six hundred and twenty-five dollars
a month being invested
without a match if that were invested in
a decent growth series of growth stock
mutual funds like we recommend growth
growth and income aggressive growth and
international outperforming the SP which
are is possible I buy mutual funds that
I performed innocent B and I also buy
some in the SP do a little both but if
that's what I'm gonna do and I did that
from age 30 to age 64 30 years
I'd have 2.2 million dollars in that
account now that would be true of
putting six hundred twenty-five dollars
into a Roth or six hundred twenty-five
dollars into traditional either one okay
it's gonna grow to the exact same amount
if it's the exact same investments in
the exact same amount dollars going in
okay so that's what we're doing now once
we've done all of that okay we look up
and at age sixty you would have around
2.2 million dollars in this account
whether it's a Roth or whether it's a
traditional now this is not counting
match so seven thousand five hundred a
year six hundred twenty-five dollars a
month from age 30 to age sixty will be
around 2.2 million dollars now if it is
in a traditional you put in the money
pre-tax and you've not paid taxes on
your contribution and the entire amount
of growth is taxable and so your
contribution and the growth is taxable
it's a tax deferred investment which is
a wonderful investment there's nothing
wrong with that but the entire 2.2
million dollars will be taxable if it is
a Roth you got your money in after-tax
so you've already paid taxes on the six
hundred twenty-five dollars a month so
you had to make more than 625 to get
through that some granted the math is
not really apples to apples but this is
the reality of people's investment
strategy so if we do that we've got 2.2
million dollars in there here's the
thing a Roth IRA grows tax-free now
you've already paid taxes on your
contribution and the growth is all
tax-free so the 2.2 million dollars
is completely tax-free now but you pay
taxes on your contributions now here's
the contribution $7,500 a year for 30
years is two hundred and twenty five
thousand dollars so out of your 2.2
million you know roughly two million
dollars of it is growth which is all
taxable in a traditional and zero taxes
in a Roth so if you paid it at a twenty
five percent tax rate this is a five
hundred thousand dollar tax bill on a
traditional over a Roth now you would
want to do that if you'd already doubled
your money with a match you don't want
to do that just because you chose the
wrong box traditional versus Roth choose
the Roth so matches first Roth because a
tax-free growth and most of your money
is growth and then if none of that is if
that doesn't get you to your fifteen
percent or you don't have those things
available for some reason then you would
do traditional and that's how you roll
the thing out and that's why we do it
that way Julia